Why do people spy on their own allies?
What motivates traitors?
US Intelligence officials have boiled down
the motives for treason to four possibilities
in the acronym ‘MICE’.
M – Money.
No explanation needed here.
It’s a motive as old as humankind.
I – Ideology.
This can be even more powerful than money.
Sometimes in the name of misguided idealism,
secret agents can turn against their own countries,
as in the case of famous Soviet double agent
Kim Philby.
C – Compromise.
Blackmail or Coercion.
An unwilling agent may be forced to hand over
secrets, lest compromising or embarrassing
details are divulged.
E – Ego.
The most dangerous and unpredictable reason.
Playing two sides can provide excitement and
a feeling of power.
Today’s protagonist, Robert Hanssen, was
an FBI agent who served his country for 20
years.
At the end of the Cold War, Hanssen sold classified
secrets to the Soviet and Russian intelligence
services.
He compromised the security of his country
and put the lives of colleagues in danger.
He realised his mistakes and stopped spying,
but eventually returned to his duplicitous
role with a vengeance.
What were his motives?
Apparently, it was a combination of Money
and Ego, but there may have been a darker
demon lurking under the façade of Hanssen,
a devout Catholic and father of six.
Let’s find out, in today’s Biographics
The Accountant
Robert Phillip Hanssen was born in Chicago,
Illinois, just weeks before D-Day, on April
18, 1944.
On the day of his birth, his father was not
there, as he was serving in the US Navy during
World War II.
In peacetime, Hanssen Sr was a Police Officer
in the Chicago Police Department.
The old man was one who would not suffer fools,
neither in the streets, nor at home.
As Robert grew up, his father was reported
to have frequently abused him, ranting that
he was a failure and would never succeed in
life.
After graduating from high school, Hanssen
attended Knox College in Illinois, where he
studied chemistry and Russian.
After graduation, he considered becoming a
dentist, but eventually he set his eyes on
completing an MBA.
He began his career as an accountant.
In 1968 Robert married his fiancée, Bernadette
Wauck, known as ‘Bonnie’.
Bonnie, a Catholic, was born in a family that
was much wealthier than Robert’s.
Influenced by her devotion, he converted to
the same faith and joined Opus Dei, an exclusive,
conservative order within the Church.
The new couple had six children and committed
to send each of them to exclusive private
schools.
In accordance with Opus Dei tradition, they
would also commit to donate a portion of their
income to the charitable works of their parish.
The Agent
This tithing lifestyle surely took its toll
on Robert’s paycheck.
Strangely, after a few years working as an
accountant, he decided to enter law enforcement,
which generally tends to be a less lucrative
career.
Regardless, Hanssen joined the forced and
worked as a policeman in Chicago for four
years.
Thanks to his background, Robert was placed
on an elite unit investigating corruption
and white-collar crimes.
After this stint with the boys in blue, Robert
decided he would join those in grey: the FBI.
At this stage he had the right CV to join
the agency.
His credentials as an accountant with an MBA,
plus four years in the Chicago anti-corruption
squad made him a good fit for the agency’s
Financial Crimes Division.
He was assigned to the Division’s headquarters
in Gary, Indiana, right out of the FBI Academy.
But even as Hanssen investigated white-collar
criminals in the Midwest, he was dreaming
of something different.
Hanssen had grown up with a fondness for espionage.
He was a huge James Bond fan, devouring Ian
Fleming’s books as well as the movies.
He had even bought a Walther PPK pistol – a
Bond favourite -- plus a Leica miniature camera,
and a shortwave radio.
For some reason, he had even opened a Swiss
bank account.
Unfortunately for Hannssen, 007 remained nothing
more than a number on one of his spreadsheets.
Hanssen, though, had reasons to hope for a
more exciting assignment.
In 1978, he filed a transfer request to the
FBI office in New York City, one of the great
spy capitals of the world.
He was assigned to the Soviet Counterintelligence
Analytical Squad.
It seemed like adventure might finally be
calling.
But it wasn’t so.
You see, Hannssen’s supervisors described
him as smart, technically proficient, and
analytical.
They marvelled at his skills with early computer
systems.
But they also considered him lacking in field
operations ability and assigned him to administrative
work.
This crushed his fantasies of going undercover,
chasing Soviet spies in the underbelly of
New York.
Hanssen’s job was to manage the New York
Field Office’s counterintelligence database.
He had joined the FBI to hunt spies, but the
agency had made him a glorified librarian.
In all honesty, the job description sounds
quite cool if you ask me.
Hanssen’s job was to assemble a database
of foreign officials posted in New York who,
while posing as diplomats, were actually intelligence
officers spying on the United States.
Many of them were agents of the main Soviet
intelligence agency, the KGB, or its military
counterpart: a larger but less famous agency,
the GRU.
This just wasn’t enough for Robert Hanssen.
The Double Agent
At this stage, Special Agent Hanssen felt
wronged by the FBI.
He also felt the increasing weight of the
bills piling up.
His growing family needed more space, and
Hanssen’s traditional stance required him
to be the main bread-winner, requiring Bonnie
to stay at home.
These may have been the reasons that pushed
him to the edge of treason for the first time.
In November 1979, Hanssen used his growing
knowledge of Soviet operations to contact
the GRU and volunteer his services.
Clever and stealthy from the start, Hanssen
concealed his identity from his Soviet contacts.
From 1979 until 1981, he left information
stolen from his department, the Soviet Counterintelligence
Unit in dead drops in exchange for a sum of
money that sources say fell somewhere between
$21,000 to $30,000.
That’s about $60 to 90,000 in today’s
money.
Dead drops are a common method used by spies
to exchange information.
Spy No. 1 drops his or her messages in an
agreed, hidden place -- behind a loose brick
on a certain wall, for example.
The spy then leaves a commonly understood
sign, such as a simple chalk mark, on another
place.
The handlers then know that they have mail
waiting and can pick up the bundle.
The intel that Hanssen provided to the Soviets
was highly valuable.
Hanssen even revealed the name of a Russian
general, Dimitri Polyakov, who had been providing
information to the Americans.
Polyakov was placed under surveillance by
the Russians; he was eventually arrested as
a spy and executed in 1988.
The Remorseful Spy
The GRU experience was a positive test for
Hanssen’s resolve and ability.
He might have continued his work for them,
but in the spring of 1980, Hanssen was caught.
One can hide secrets from the FBI, the GRU,
the KGB even – but not from a spouse.
Bonnie found a strange letter from the GRU
to Hanssen in the basement of their house
in Scarsdale, New York.
Hanssen downplayed it.
He told Bonnie that he had been giving the
Soviets junk information, to trick them into
giving him money.
In a later testimony, Bonnie said that she
demanded that her husband go with her to see
their Roman Catholic priest to confess.
They then drove to New Rochelle to meet with
Rev. Robert Bucciarelli, a priest also associated
with Opus Dei.
Father Bucciarelli came up with a plan: if
Robert gave the money from the Soviets to
charity, and promised not to spy again, as
a good boy, the priest committed not to report
the matter to the FBI.
Which in theory he shouldn’t have done anyways,
as confessions are protected by an oath of
secrecy, but … whatever.
Hanssen agreed.
Bonnie, who at the time was expecting their
fourth child, was greatly relieved, but she
was also determined to hold her husband to
the deal.
Robert admitted that he had already spent
most of the GRU money, but Bonnie insisted
that he repay to charity the full original
amount.
He began to make small payments over several
years to a charity affiliated with Mother
Teresa's Catholic organization, which moved
the family close to bankruptcy.
Over the following years, Bonnie kept close
tabs on Robert, checking if he was making
the payments, and even questioning him on
whether he was still working with the Russians.
It seems to me like the FBI would have been
wise to hire Bonnie Hannssen.
In the early 1980s, Hanssen was transferred
to FBI headquarters in Washington, D.C.
To his colleagues in the bureau, who were
still oblivious to his actual conduct, he
seemed to be a model agent.
In office chit-chat, Hanssen often spoke of
his engagement with Opus Dei and appeared
to be a devoted Catholic and anti-communist.
From 1981 until 1985, he served in the Budget
and Soviet Analytical Units at FBI headquarters.
He may still have been a desk jockey, but
one nested at the centre of a web of information
flowing to and from the intelligence division.
As one of the few skilled computer operators,
Hannssen’s cyber tendrils took in information
from the NSA and the CIA, reviewing info on
the FBI’s most sensitive human assets and
technical operations against the USSR.
Finally, Hanssen realized that the best spies
were not flashy James Bonds, but rather, the
smart men and women who lurked in the shadows,
manipulating information, unnoticed and unknown.
In September 1985, Hanssen returned to the
New York Field Office.
This time he supervised a foreign counterintelligence
squad, which gave him access to a wealth of
Soviet spy information.
This included the identity of the FBI’s
Soviet sources and informants, as well as
the locations of KGB defectors in the US.
Emboldened by his former success with the
GRU, Hanssen graduated to the big league.
He was going to spy
for
the KGB.
The Unrepentant Spy
In October 4, 1985, Soviet diplomat Viktor
Degtyar received a strange looking envelope
in his house in Alexandria, Virginia.
Degtyar opened the envelope and found a second
sealed envelope inside.
A note with instructions forbade Degtyar from
opening the second envelope and demanded he
take it to his colleague Victor Cherkashin.
It was clear to Degtyar that whoever had sent
the envelope was aware that he was, in fact,
a KGB officer of the PR Line.
The KGB organized its espionage activities
into distinct lines, or sections, with different
intelligence and counterintelligence responsibilities.
The ‘PR’ collected information about political,
economic, and military strategic intelligence.
Each line of activity came under the direction
of the KGB rezident, an official member of
the Soviet Embassy who was in fact a covert
spymaster.
Cherkashin was Viktor’s rezident.
The next day Degtyar handed over the package
to Cherkashin, a veteran spy who had also
been the handler of Aldrich Ames, the CIA’s
most dangerous mole.
The letter read
“Dear Mr. Cherkashin:
Soon, I will send a box of documents to Mr.
Degtyar.
They are from certain of the most sensitive
and highly compartmented projects of the U.S.
Intelligence community.
All are originals to aid in Verifying their
authenticity.
…
I trust that an officer of your experience
will handle them appropriately.
I believe they are sufficient to justify a
$100,000 payment to me.
I must warn of certain risks to your security
of which you may not be aware.
Your service has recently suffered some setbacks.
I warn that
Mr. Boris Yuzhin
Mr. Sergey Motorin and
Mr. Valeriy Martynov
have been recruited by our special services.
My identity and actual position in the community
must be left unstated to ensure my security.
I will add 6, (you Subtract 6) from stated
months, days and times in both directions
of our future communications.”
And then, as a signature, a simple
“B”
Cherkashin had struck gold.
Three double agents exposed in one stroke,
simply by opening an envelope.
And Hanssen had scored a 100 grand.
His first letter to Cherkashin had also caused
enormous damage.
The FBI and CIA relied on Yuzhin, Motorin,
and Martynov to spy for the US and provide
critical inside information about Soviet espionage
operations.
After Hanssen’s letter, the KGB flew each
of the spies back to Moscow and tried them
for espionage.
After sham trials, the Soviets executed Motorin
and Martynov.
Yuzhin received a fifteen-year sentence.
From 1985 to 1991, Hanssen handed to the KGB
some of the most important counterintelligence
and military secrets in the hands of US security
services.
By 1991, Hanssen had completely compromised
the FBI’s counter-intelligence database.
Meanwhile, Hanssen was counting his money
at his FBI desk, laughing while the agency
looked for the mole in all the wrong places.
He could have easily been caught at this time.
During a visit from her brother, Mark Wauck,
Bonnie had confided to him that she was alarmed.
She had found $5,000 in cash at home, and
feared that Robert may have started spying
for the Russians again.
Mark was an FBI agent himself, although based
in Chicago.
He reported this to his supervisors in 1990,
but they didn’t take any meaningful action!
In the following years Robert managed to avoid
detection, as he skilfully worked with the
KGB handlers without ever meeting them.
In one occasion, he slipped up, speaking to
a Russian agent over a pay phone – this
could have easily given him away, as presumably
all Soviet Embassy lines were tapped.
But again, nothing happened.
In general, Hanssen and Degtyar relied on
a system of dead drops and signals placed
in public places.
For instance, a piece of adhesive tape placed
on a sign in a park in Virginia would indicate
that a package had been placed under a small
footbridge in the park.
In 1991, the Soviet Union collapsed.
This was bad news for Hanssen.
During the early 1990s, KGB veterans began
to approach western intelligence agencies
and spill the beans on their recent operations.
Hanssen became alarmed: what if a Russian
with knowledge of his activities signaled
the Americans to his true identity?
For eight years, Hanssen behaved liked a boy
scout – at least spy-wise.
He stopped contacting the Russians, while
waiting for the inevitable arrest.
Again, nothing happened.
So, in 1999, while working as an FBI liaison
with the State Department, he fell back into
bad habits and started selling American secrets
again.
Little did he know that a former colleague
on the other side of the former Iron Curtain
had begun doing exactly the same thing.
A former KGB agent had come across Hanssen's
KGB file and contacted US intelligence with
the intention of selling it.
Realizing the importance of the material,
the US paid $7 million for it.
In 20 years of selling classified intel, Hanssen
had racked up approximately $1.4 Million dollars.
This Russian guy, in perhaps two months of
work, had made $7 Million!
Either the Americans had deeper pockets, or
Hanssen was a terrible negotiator.
The dossier sold to the Americans did not
specify the mole’s name.
Evidence in the file, though, pointed to Hanssen,
and he was put under close surveillance from
Special Agent O’Neill, a younger colleague
who posed as his assistant.
The net was closing in.
Hanssen’s Demons
On February 18, 2001, Hanssen was arrested
at a park in northern Virginia after he had
placed a package at his usual dead drop location.
The evidence against him was overwhelming,
and to avoid the death penalty, Hanssen confessed
and agreed to be debriefed by American intelligence
officials.
In May 2002, Hanssen was sentenced to life
in prison.
News reports claimed that intelligence agencies
were not entirely satisfied with the extent
of his cooperation -- they believed he was
holding back information.
But the Government could not prove he had
lied, and wishing to avoid a public trial,
they did not void his plea agreement.
The Hanssen case was regarded as a low point
for the FBI.
Hanssen had been trusted by his superiors,
he could have been stopped in more than one
occasion and his betrayal had gone undetected
for years.
The Government stated that Hanssen had been
paid approximately $1.4 million during his
spying career, although most of it was held
in a Russian bank account.
The damage Hanssen did was catastrophic.
At least three Russian double agents had been
executed or imprisoned because of him, and
it was suspected that he compromised dozens
of intelligence operations.
For example, he had sold the information that
the Americans had dug a tunnel under the Russian
embassy in Washington, to install listening
devices.
Hanssen was incarcerated in the "supermax"
federal prison in Colorado.
Fellow convicts include the Unabomber, one
of the Boston Marathon bombers, and a number
of organized crime figures.
But why did Hanssen betray his country?
During his sessions with investigators, Hanssen
claimed his motivation had always been financial.
Yet some investigators believed anger about
how his father treated him as a child triggered
a need to rebel against authority.
Author Eric O’Neill, on the other hand,
speculated that his motives lay in his egomania
and thirst for adventure.
The man himself told his investigators what
had sparked his spying:
“Fear and rage.
Fear of being a failure and fear of not being
able to provide for my family.”
Hanssen said he felt “rage” towards the
FBI each time he was denied a promotion.
He was determined to prove they had made a
mistake in not promoting him by pulling off
increasingly large-scale feats of espionage.
Hanssen was convinced that other FBI agents
lacked his commitment to the bureau.
And the bureau, in his view, was not fighting
the Russians in the right way.
As reporters dug deeper into the case, more
disturbing psychological demons started to
emerge.
Friends of Hanssen told journalists that he
had exhibited eccentric behaviour, which included
an obsession with pornography and sex in general.
Lesley Stahl from CBS reported that Hanssen
had taken the habit of sending nude pictures
of his wife to a friend of his.
He even posted sexually explicit online stories
about Bonnie on the Internet.
Hanssen got to the point of inviting his friend
to watch a live stream of him having sex with
Bonnie on a secretly installed CCTV system.
Bonnie knew nothing about any of this.
Hanssen's erratic behaviour escalated, including
numerous visits to strip clubs, where he tried
to convert strippers to Catholicism.
Psychiatrist Alan Salerian was hired – and
later fired - by Hanssen's defense team to
examine him.
According to Dr Salerian, spying for the Soviets,
for the devoutly religious Hanssen, was a
way to escape those sexual problems.
"[Hanssen's] espionage was an escape from
his sexual demons.
When he found himself in exciting, dangerous
positions, such as espionage and spying, he
found that his demons slowed down.
He is driven by demons…by thoughts, unwanted
thoughts."
Dr. Salerian, who spent 30 hours interviewing
Hanssen, concluded that the double agent was
no amoral.
He was simply an ill man, suffering from a
"severe psychological disorder" of sexual
nature, who could find respite from his torments
only by putting himself in risky situations.
MICE … ?
In 2007 Special Agent O’Neill, instrumental
in Hanssen’s capture, worked with director
and screen writer Billy Ray on the film “Breach”,
a realistic portrayal of the last year of
Hanssen’s career.
Author Eric O’Neill published ‘Gray Day’
in 2013, also about Hanssen’s story, in
which he is depicted as America’s first
Cyber Spy.
Spies, secret agents, and the intelligence
community will always capture our imagination,
especially when their activities appear to
be outside of the boundaries of our accepted
morality.
What can lead a man to sell and betray his
colleagues and the security of his country?
If you look at the MICE set of motives, most
of the time it can be because of money; or
a true belief in lofty ideal; or maybe he
has been blackmailed and strong-armed; or
maybe it is just down to one’s ego and the
need to feed it.
Hanssen’s betrayal ultimately may have been
down to his ego, but not as a way to satisfy
it, rather to placate those obsessions he
could not control.
We hinted at another ‘mole’ or traitor
in our video today, but please let us know
if you would like to hear the story of another
double agent we may have not heard of.
Comment till your fingers drop, share, like,
subscribe and as usual … thank you for watching!